well now we turn to another top story
that is the imperative reopening of this
country in a safe way that is also
urgent it's time to get moving
let's take a look our country wants to
open the governor's it's in their hands
but our country wants to open and you
see what's going on they have to open
and the people of our country should
think of themselves as warriors our
country has to open President Trump is
right the pandemic is far from over
Americans there are not going to cower
in fear I think we see the American
people have assessed the danger they
have looked at what we've learned and
we've learned a lot and the probably the
biggest lesson coming from the great
state of Florida and that would be
governor Ron de Santos who did the best
job almost the best job there were a
couple of other governors in the country
he protected the elderly and the sick
and the vulnerable in other words the
opposite of what New York and
Connecticut and Michigan did it is time
to get our country back to work
let's take a look our country has to go
back to being our country again you have
people that are not going to stand for
this and I understand them very well the
University of Washington saying we could
have a hundred and thirty-five thousand
Americans dead by August what do you
make of those numbers mr. president a
couple of things first of all these
models have been so wrong from day one
both on the low side of the upside
they've been so wrong they've been so
out of whack and they keep making new
models new models and they're room those
models that you're mentioning are
talking about without mitigation well
we're mitigating and we've learned to
mitigate but we can be in place working
place and also mitigate and the travel
ban January 31st ten days after the
first known identified corona corona
virus case in America Wow
president didn't do that it would have
been exponentially worse on every level
let's face it all these models have been
dead wrong and decisions were made based
on bad models on both sides in the past
few weeks we have seen the supposed
scientific
models they get revised down and up and
up and down remember the initial death
projections were over 2.2 million
Americans way off base but the
president's travel ban no denying and
quarantine and subsequent travel ban
saved incalculable numbers of lies in
this country his historic medical
mobilization led by the president also
saved this country from untold amounts
of suffering look at your screen no
country has tested more than the United
States of America and as you can see it
is not even close now this kind of
progress on testing was almost
unthinkable just two months ago
ultimately the doom and gloom
predictions thankfully never came true
worst case scenario never happened in
large part because of that hysterical
racist xenophobic fear-mongering travel
ban of the president ten days after the
first case for some reason the rhetoric
on the left gets more and more
hysterical they were busy impeaching the
president someone over there a fake news
CNN actually suggesting that going
outside getting fresh air is a betrayal
to health care workers these people over
there are fake news are nuts take a look
the president seems to be saying that
it's safe to go to the parks and the
beaches does that argument make any
sense to you no and I think in in some
ways it really betrays the really
hundreds of thousands of people in the
United States who work in hospitals day
and night to try and save lives
this is coming from the top and it's
incredibly destructive everyone in
medicine knows this socially distant
wearing masks sorry you guys are nuts
and I bet none of you supported the
travel ban either now while the mob and
the media they're apparently rooting for
an indefinite shutdown well the American
people they know better they're fighting
back this is not mission accomplished
not until as the president said it's
completely soft still we are now working
on getting the country back to working
back to work safely same time preventing
predictable new hot spots from emerging
and pouncing on them if and when they do
and now Americans
let's do what we do best that's create
innovate and work like hell to rebuild
the country make no mistake this kind of
exceptionalism is not derived from big
government that was the case well let's
see the former Soviet Union would be the
best place on earth to live or Venezuela
tough choices will be made precautions
will be taken they're necessary but its
interim won't last forever many people
are struggling look at this one Dallas
salon owner who was given seven days in
jail for reopening too soon the judge
told her she could avoid punishment if
she apologizes for her actions she
refused good for her because beating her
kids was more important and it's
interesting how creative people are when
they are opening Oh plexiglass mass
social distancing they're doing it all
they learned America learned this is why
we can reopen and do it safely like the
state of Florida did not the state of
New York not the state of Michigan
millions of Americans across the country
are experiencing a lot of hardship
another example out in California their
tourism industry could lose well as much
as seventy two billion dollars by the
way that is not the people of
Tennessee's responsibility in Michigan
almost every business is suffering
because of dozens of insane
authoritarian measures from their
left-wing governor touted to be Biden
the ever forgetful one's vice
presidential running mate
now pursuant to an executive order that
recently expired witmer ban let's see
jet skis motor boats gun stores shooting
ranges camping at campgrounds she forced
retailers to close their plant sections
she banned lawyers and realtors from
leaving their homes for work and she
even banned lawn and garden services
closed golf courses car washers
showrooms for cars and and bicycle shops
and private construction and the list
could go on and on just dumb draconian a
lot of this and it has done and she had
done an awful job of trying to protect
the people in her state instead of
focusing her state's most vulnerable
communities focus on them the elderly
nursing homes
she enacted broad measures for everyone
meanwhile Florida governor
the exact opposite and the numbers they
speak for themselves by far he did one
of the best jobs in the country look at
your screen
well numbers tell the whole story
fatality rate at Florida's long-term
care facilities drastically lower than
Michigan and obviously New York's
numbers are the worse because they
didn't use the 3,000 beds at the Javits
Center that the president manned and
built and converted to Cova 19 patients
they used a thousand of the 3000 beds
they only used 182 beds at the hospital
ship the Navy ship the comfort 182 built
for a thousand Kovac Ovid 19 converted
nope
March 25th executive order sent all the
Cova 19 patients back into the long-term
facilities and oh by the way that's what
30% of the people in New York died and
by the way the fatality rate New York's
long term facilities 18% Florida just
over 1% they have some of the lard
they're the largest elderly population
in the country Santa's got it right
Cuomo Whitmer they all got it wrong
maybe just maybe it has something to do
with Governor Cuomo's insane policy
nursing homes admit and readmit patients
who test positive for coronavirus and
I'm not responsible for your PPE what at
one point it got so bad New York was
reportedly sending elderly coronavirus
patients back to these nursing homes
with body bags they did that all over
the state